hasbro and lego released the toys for
thor 11 thunder let me tell you why it's
a big deal now finding out that peter
dinklage is returning and this is why
first let me quote what he said in the
interview well there's another thor
movie there isn't there and coming out
that's tyka's directed but i didn't say
anything i didn't say anything the
interesting part here is that in the
toys we do have a cracked mjolnir that
obviously is repaired i wonder and i am
theorizing that he will return as the
king elf eatery uh we first saw him in
infinity war and he will most likely be
the reason that we do have the repaired
mjolnir i know there was speculation as
to
how we would get the mjolnir in
natalie portman's mighty thor's hands
because obviously it was cracked in thor
ragnarok and i believe we do have
confirmation now through this
apparent bombshell that he did drop that
he would be returning um i pretty much
believe that this will be his
only
role in the movie uh i doubt he'll
play a big part i mean i'm not sure
uh if it's necessary to have him in the
rest of the movie uh but let me know
down below what you guys think i mean do
you guys think that this is the possible
reason why he would be returning uh as a
way to repair mjolnir iv now the forms
of mighty thor um it's a very possible
and plausible uh theory for
thor love and thunder and let me tell
you that's exciting because i think he
did a great job in the few minutes that
he was in infinity war anyways uh please
subscribe turn on notifications i am
doing this every day i'll see you guys
tomorrow